Welcome back.
So let's continue
where we left off.
So we had this intuition that i
must have something to do with
these sign changes, right?
The pattern of the sign changes
of i are very similar to the
pattern of the sign changes in
the Maclaurin representation of
cosine of x plus sine of x.
And then we also saw that the
i's, whether they're positive
i's or negative i's,
correspond to the sine terms.
So let's do a
little experiment.
And it's not an experiment
because I know where this
leads to, but it could
have been an experiment.
What is e to the i x?
Well, raising anything to the
i power really isn't defined.
I mean, i, itself, was
created by a definition.
We said, "i squared is equal to
negative 1 by definition." So
i is a bit of a definition.
So if we haven't defined what
something to the i power is
yet, we really don't know
what to do with it.
But let's just say that
we can treat i just
like any other number.
And we do know what happens
with i when you put
it into a polynomial.
That's one thing we do know.
In fact, that's one of the
reasons why i was defined in
first place was so that people
could take roots of all
polynomials, even ones that
didn't have real roots.
So what happens if we
take e to the i x?
Well, I don't know what that is
but we know we could put that
into the Maclaurin
representation of e to the x
and actually, since you're
taking my leap of faith, that
that is equal to e of x and all
of its derivatives are equal to
e to the x's derivatives at x
equals 0, it's not
that hard to imagine.
And actually, you could plot
the graph of this and you'll
see that they're identical.
So if we take the Maclaurin
representation of this,
everywhere we see an x we just
replace it with an i x, right?
So that will be 1 plus i x plus
-- let me just write it -- plus
i squared x squared
over 2 factorial.
Oops. i squared x squared plus
i to the third x to the third
over 3 factorial plus i to the
fourth x to the fourth over 4
factorial plus i to the fifth x
to the fifth over 5 factorial.
I don't have to keep going.
Plus, and it just
keeps going, right?
So what happens when
you simplify that?
So that equals 1 plus i
x -- What's i squared?
That's negative 1, right?
-- minus x squared
over 2 factorial.
What's i to the third?
That's minus i.
So it's minus i x to the
third over 3 factorial
plus i to the fourth.
So what's i to the fourth?
That's just 1 again.
So we get plus x to the
fourth over 4 factorial.
And then we have --
what's i to the fifth?
Plus i times x to the
fifth over 5 factorial.
It just keeps going.
We have something
interesting here.
Now, all of a sudden, we have
something extremely similar to
this except for only
one difference.
Compare that to e to the i x.
The dots on my i's
always get merged.
Compare these 2 things
that I'm circling.
What's the difference?
Let's see the 1, 1.
Well, here, I have an
x, I have an i x here.
Then minus x squared
over 2 fact -- so these
terms are the same.
Then on the x to the third, the
signs are right but have an i.
And then, x to the fourth over
4 factorial -- that's identical
-- but then on x to the
fifth, I have an i.
So the only difference between
this and this is on the terms
that involve sin of x, right?
So what are the terms
that involve sin of x?
This term corresponds
to that term, right?
to that term.
These are the terms that
correspond to sin of x
in this representation.
That term corresponds
to that term.
And the only difference is --
so this has all of the terms
that the sin of x would have
but they all have an i in
front of them, right?
Even the sign is right.
This is negative,
that's negative.
But this just has an
i in front of it.
So it turns out, that you
could rewrite this, right?
You could rewrite
this representation.
Well, it doesn't turn out.
It's pretty obvious
you could rewrite it.
Let me clear this
just so we get a --
So we could actually
rewrite that e to the i x.
And we could write it -- we
could separate out the
imaginary terms and we could
separate out the real terms.
What were the real terms?
Well, the real terms were 1
minus x squared over 2
factorial plus x to the fourth
over 4 factorial minus x to the
sixth over 6 factorial.
And it just kept going
to infinity, right?
Those were the real terms.
That's to infinity dot dot dot.
This pen tool looks
like minus signs.
I don't want to do that.
Oh, I can't undo it.
So this is just dot dot dot.
So those are the real
terms, essentially.
And then, the imaginary terms
-- it was plus -- well, all of
these terms are going to
have i on them, right?
So let me just take the i out.
So, plus i times -- and we
figured out that those terms
were x minus -- well, I don't
want to give it away too fast
-- x to the third
over 3 factorial.
Plus x to the fifth over 5
factorial minus x to the
seventh over 7 factorial and
it just kept going on, on,
and on to infinity, right?
Well isn't this the Maclaurin
representation of cosine of x?
And similarly, isn't this the
Maclaurin representation
of sin of x?
Well yeah, sure.
And you probably realized it in
the previous screen where I
showed that all of the
imaginary terms corresponded
to the sin of x terms.
And all the real ones,
likewise, were the cosine of x
when we we compared it to sin
of x plus cosine of x.
So if you believe me, that the
Maclaurin representation of e
to the x is equal to e to the x
and the Maclaurin
representation of cosine and
sin of x are equal to those
functions, then all of a
sudden, we come up with this
bizarre and amazing and
mystical idea that e to the i x
is equal to cosin of x plus i
times the sin of x.
And this is called
Euler's formula.
And actually e
stands for Euler.
That's where it comes from.
Euler starts with an E.
E U L E R.
But this is amazing.
Not only have we found a
relationship between this
bizarre, mystical, magical
number, e, and these
trigonometric functions that we
defined as a ratio of the sides
of right triangles, but now
we're involving this other
mystical, magical number that
we invented just so that all of
our polynomials would have some
root, whether or not
they're real or not.
We have this number, i, all
of a sudden showing up.
This by itself is amazing.
But now we can take it one
step further and this
should blow your mind.
If it doesn't, then
you have no emotion.
I will just judge you.
So if we take this and,
essentially, we're taking it
that when you take something to
the i power, that you can just
substitute it into this
Maclaurin repres -- but I
won't go into the details.
But I think you can say
that this is a pretty
reasonable proposition.
But what happens if we take
something to the pi power?
If e to the i pi power?
Before, we didn't have any
way of saying, "Well,
what does that mean?
Taking something to the i pi
power?" But now we do because
we're saying that these
2 sides of this are
equal to each other.
So what happens?
Let me do this in a bold color
because it deserves to be bold.
e to the i pi is equal to well,
where x is pi, is equal to
cosine of pi plus i sin of pi.
Well what's cosine of pi?
This is equal to negative 1.
And sin of pi, well
that's just equal to 0.
We get e to the i pi is
equal to negative 1.
This is amazing.
Or you could also write e to
the i pi plus 1 is equal to 0.
Once again, amazing.
Either of these should make you
question your take on reality
because we have the number pi,
which is a ratio of a
circumference of a
circle to its diameter.
We have the number, e, that
comes from a continuous
compound interest.
And then we have the number, i,
which you can say the square
root of negative 1 or it
squared is negative 1.
And they all come together.
This formula right here
involves all the fundamental
numbers in mathematics but
they come from completely
different directions.
Completely different
directions.
And although we can prove this
and we can say this is true,
I'll tell you no one -- no one
-- probably in the history
of mankind, fully
understands why this is.
This is just a glimpse on some
type of order in the universe.